the pay gap
okay the pay gap yeah um but the pay
gap's not real it still is no it's not
it is
um no every the thing is like when you
take into
account things like like personality
differences the pay gap doesn't exist
like like um for example google did a
study
on like they thought they were paying
women less than men
and they found out they were paying then
eight percent left when they take into
account things like hours worked and
their time time their experience
like there's no there's no pay gap
okay fair enough i don't have statistics
so i will
yeah pass
well
i don't have the statistics to back it
up but
okay i believe it when you say it yeah
okay
it's okay um i i think it's like common
to be honest like a lot of people
like that it's kind of pushed in the
media and stuff but any like economist
that's worth a damn will tell you the
pickup doesn't exist
like women
women aren't into like we make 70 to 80
of consumer buying decisions the entire
media is marketed to women
so i don't know what i'm just curious
like what are we fighting for in 2022 i
mean when it comes to the pay gap it's
like um
it's like this if you advertise a job
on the internet
and say this job is
x and this is the salary
it's not oh this is a salary for women
and this is salary for men right it says
this is the salary so
every person that applies for that job
whether you be male or female is going
to get that salary and one of the major
reasons went for the pay gap is that we
talked about uh men being more
disagreeable and women be more agreeable
so in a job
men are more likely to fight for a pay
rise than a woman is did you know 60
percent of women have never asked for a
pay rise yeah 60 percent so what happens
is that men get into these positions
okay it was i don't know seventy
thousand a year
and it's like they start doing their
work and they're like hang on a minute
i'm doing all of these hours i'm doing
all of this work as a matter of fact i
think i deserve a raise and they go to
the boss and say look
i deserve a raise and so men are
more uh
let's just say forthright with asking
for pay rises so a lot of the time
within the
pay gap is because men have actually
taken the time out to say you know what
i want more women are like yeah you know
what i'm not really going to go and ask
the boss for more money and stuff and
yeah all right i'm fine with the job
it's a good job men are like no i'm
doing all these hours and generally men
work more hours than women
they just generally do so a lot of the
time the pay gap is because men work
more hours than women do
um men work
harder jobs than women do
men work in more so in the stem fields
there's
science technology engineering
mathematics not to say women can't go
into those stem fields
we have the same equal opportunities
that you do
you can go into science technology
engineering and mathematics those are
very high paying
jobs but women choose generally not to
go into those fields they choose to go
into other fields so that's one of the
reasons for the pay gap but there's
women on those fields yeah there are and
they get paid the same as men but in
those fields men choose to yeah get more
aggressive and say listen i deserve more
yeah but probably some women are afraid
to actually ask for more because
probably the boss is a male and he will
say no and most of the times they say no
because you are a woman and they see us
less in a way and actually we are living
in a men's society and let's be honest
still
we need feminism you know but we're not
living in america why do you say we live
in the man society sorry like how are we
living in a man's society of 70 to 80
percent because women are afraid still
to ask for a raise
why are you afraid i'm not i'm not i'm
always asking for more every year so
yeah and i i get it but why but so why
women why are women afraid then i i
don't know because they probably they've
been in that place and they've been
rejected you know or probably they never
like you said before as well they don't
have the same uh
you know god's feeling as men
like going forward and ask for more but
we
we know as women
i i that's my uh that's my i say that's
how i think and that's how i feel and
that's how i see women back back but
ages ago
but that doesn't mean you're right like
i'm a girl i've always i don't want it
but i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying
i'm saying i've always been in male
dominated fields i've never had anything
it's been easier for me because like i'm
young and like like men
i feel like men are more inclined to
help girls they're attracted to like
just being 100 yeah and it's like i feel
like i've gotten more opportunity being
a girl and you stand out more
like like i was in sales i sold copiers
and like i never had an issue i always
got help from men i never had a problem
asking for more money but then men shame
us
i actually
saw one time a man saying oh why men why
women wear makeup while they are going
to their you know workplace because they
are trying to seduce they are trying you
know to get their way
to get what they want probably you know
so you see we are ashamed by men as well
but the the reason is because we use our
looks we are shamed by me if you don't
do it
by mentioning you know it's just like do
you think we have always something to
you know to get judged by men do you and
that's why yeah you know
women are afraid to ask
if you're if but if you're afraid and
that's on you no i'm just saying not me
i'm saying women in general if they're
afraid that's on them and the thing is
we as a man i understand like men
men deal with men a certain way and men
understand like male energy so if a man
goes to a man he understands okay cool
another man's coming to me
cool we have to
you know deal with this male energy
if women are afraid to deal with men in
this in this society then i think that's
a that's a woman problem isn't it
because we can have a conversation like
every person has male and female energy
as a man and as a woman we both have
those energies and i think of course a
woman has to learn uh how to deal with
that energy and use for her benefit as a
man as well you know has to be
understanding and more
like to listen more women
than rather like judging you know so
when it comes like a woman to actually
ask for
like to read to raise their i'm sorry my
english is a bit i stumble but anyway
if he if a woman asks more she's always
seen as a gold eager or
um i don't think you are worth as a man
doing that the same job i think he does
better you know wait who is that is that
factual is that something that you just
feel yeah cause who does that like
that's never like that's never happened
to me but that's you right but it's just
one or two you know you
you know it happens it it can happen in
that way too but it can happen the other
side as well you know this role is quite
big there's a lot of people i don't
believe there is like equality when it
comes to be paid everywhere
well
well i don't believe it the statistics
will you can also go wrong
you can
say like donald trump you know there's a
lot of statistics about a lot of it and
when we see like real life like real
cases
close people
then so are you saying you'd believe
what you believe regardless of any data
and statistics put in front of you like
it does it doesn't matter any any data
it's just like what you
believe
um
i like i like to see real cases like i i
heard a lot about statistics and then
you just hear like stories about real
people well i'm a real person
but i'm a real person i know but like so
sorry for the statistics then i'm just
saying right people who are not they
exist as well you know so we cannot
generalize all of it
sure sure but i'm saying like it's just
interesting that it doesn't like because
to me if you gave me counter evidence or
counter data that like show showed that
the pay gap was real
then sure i would look at it and maybe
change my opinion but i've just i've
researched this a lot because of the
channel
and like i'm telling you there's study
after study after study after study
saying that
the the pay gap
if there is one it's as close as three
percent
and some studies say that women are paid
more than men
so
so it's just like how can i look at all
this evidence and not
have a different opinion you know what i
mean and i understand it's not in front
of you maybe you don't take my word for
it that's fine like you don't you don't
have to believe me but that's what i'm
asking like if you had these studies in
front of you would that change your
opinion or would you just keep
i'm not doubting what are you saying i'm
just saying i believe there's still
cases out there women are not being paid
like
you know as men like the same that's
what i'm saying okay yeah yeah all right
no i was gonna say like i understand
where you're coming from because
i
i thought that as well
after seeing a video of
jordan
jordan
jordan peterson just wanted to get his
name right he was talking about it and
he's he's not just some joe smo off the
street but he was talking he's a
psychologist very well known professor
and everything he's very good video he
was talking about how
the reason why there is
or
if there is a pay gap is not based on
someone being a man or a woman but
there's
traits that because you were saying
if men and women have those male uh
those masculine and feminine traits and
if
a woman would
essentially tap into those
male traits
they would be able to walk up to whoever
it is and be like i deserve to be paid
more because that's a trait that
masculinity has there
it's that like dog in them to be able to
be like no i deserve this but we as
women we
is it empathy or it's agreeable we're
more agreeable we're more agreeable and
it's just who we are so it's a little
bit more difficult for us to be able to
step out not saying that there's not
cases where
women do get paid less than men but
they're also on the flip side where in
certain industry
men do get paid less than women
so like when you take modeling for
example
like women get paid more than men in
that industry yeah supermodels yeah
female supermodels get paid
would you would you like equality in the
supermodel world like the men get paid
as much as the women
yeah makes sense i mean about modeling
let's see like for example kendall
jenner she's like one of the most
i think it's the first
billionaire yeah yeah i mean but she
even comparing to other women as well
yeah but i'm saying like if you look at
history when it comes to modeling right
like
supermodels
being women have been paid
far much more than men
like but men aren't saying oh my god we
need equality within the modeling
industry we need to be paid because
there are male models out there and they
do you know they have campaigns and what
but they don't get paid as much as the
women do so they didn't speak up for
that
right exactly so but they could speak
out they they could exactly
it's their choice but i'm saying
so do you think that male models should
be paid as much as female models yeah
why not if you guys do the same job why
not what's the difference here
for me it's about equality it's not i
don't see a man or
a woman more or less i see as we both
are the same level you know we are
humans we are people it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter the gender you know
for me you are a person like me you are
a human you are the same as me we are
the same [ __ ] i'm just saying of course
we are different in gender but when it
comes to rights i think we all deserve
the same so then why so then okay so
let's put that into the real world so
then why would uh why is a woman more
likely to get into a club for free than
a man is
well i didn't do the rule i didn't do
the rules do you think i'm saying
equality that men actually do the rule
you know why because they want more
women in the club than men so they
attract men to pay the bill
right so there's men are the hungry ones
to get more money so that makes sense
you guys did the math so that double
stance
right so that double standard there that
double standard was created by men right
but it but you're okay with that though
oh yeah because we get in for free right
okay so that's right
that's important that's it
that's the point that's the point so
you're okay with double standards when
it when it when it benefits you
you're not okay with double standards
when it doesn't benefit us
if you are getting paid more doesn't it
even if we don't get paid more or the
same as you guys it doesn't like we
don't take your benefits do we no yes
you in some cases yes when you implement
things like quotas i'll give you an
example i worked in the copier industry
they needed women because selling
copiers honestly is a [ __ ] job i don't
know a lot of girls that want to do it i
shouldn't do it right right
i shouldn't have done it but then they
hired any girl that walked through the
door
whether or not it was she was qualified
or not because they needed women they
needed to fill their quotas
and like then you have unqualified women
in jobs they don't deserve
and so and then that hurts men because
you're taking away opportunities from
people that actually are qualified and
deserve them
but the person who to blame here is not
the women who are hired is the person
who hires the people
no the the person to blame is the person
that implemented a quota
because that's not no no we we women we
came here to get you know our rights
uh-huh but not to say oh i deserve a job
even though i'm not qualified i'm not
coming from there but essentially that's
what
in my eyes that's what feminism is it's
just like it doesn't matter
what it is
it should be a right for a woman
so no matter if you're qualified or not
you should be able to
get the job
i don't know because i don't agree with
that then
i don't i don't i don't see you in that
way yeah
yeah that's earlier you're asking for
like equality when you're like man women
should be paid the same it should be
equal but the question is like equal at
what cost
so
so if you if you just pay people the
same if like you say a man and a woman
they're equal but what if one does a
better job than the other
and if you take into account like if you
look at the studies men work longer
hours than women
because you decide to stay long yeah and
so so if you work longer hours you
should get paid more yeah but then good
so then the page like so then that's
extra right so then the pet so then you
can't complain about the pay gap
no exactly you're right i i'm with you
but i'm saying like so then when men
start making more money we cannot
complain you can't complain we work more
hours let me just clarify when i said
page up i don't mean people that work
that men that work extra hours i meant
people that do the exact same job that
have the exact same qualifications
getting paid exactly that's exactly
right
people are not qualified that's that's
your problem no but then so then like
that's that's what it seems like on the
outside but you can't look at it at face
value
because you have to look as to why is
there that gap and so another aspect is
personality differences like what jess
was saying earlier so 60 of women
haven't asked for a raise ever and
they'll quit their job before they ask
for a raise
so is that is that men's fault that we
chose not to ask for a raise because i i
have a friend who works in
can't exactly remember she works in but
she makes a good amount of money and
when she got a new position
she was like should i ask for a raise
and i was like yes asked for it and when
she asked for a certain amount of money
that was uh similar to her counterparts
which were males she got it and i think
it's just
something that has been subconsciously
talked to us like don't ask for raise
that's going to be rude if you ask for
more money that they've already
given you when it's not rude if you
think you are worth a certain amount of
money and you are qualified for a
position to go and ask it something that
we've been
just taught as women it's like don't do
something because
it may ruffle somebody's feather we have
to be peacemakers we can't upset anybody
we have to be calm in the situation and
i think that's one reason why
we don't do certain things as women
because we don't want to upset anybody
or
make anybody feel like we're ungrateful
for something that they've already
given us when we shouldn't have to feel
like that if we think that we're worth
something because in a relationship if
you feel like you're worth more in a
relationship you're going to get out of
that relationship no matter how long it
may take you you're going to be like i'm
worth more in this relationship i'm
going to step out of it